ladies and gentlemen welcome to geek
culture explained as you can tell from
the sound of my voice this isn't Rob but
uh hopefully that didn't immediately
just result in you tuning out of this
video because that would be really
awkward and deflating if I can be quite
vulnerable Rob's actually on vacation
and asked me to cover for him which
means that if you love Rob you are
hereby obligated to love me as well my
name is Karan and many of you may
remember me from the morbius Press
junket I appreciate all of you who gave
me a warm welcome in the comments and
even the constructive criticism on my
often conversational approach to
conducting interviews what I find really
funny about some of the less flattering
comments that I promise you I didn't
obsessively go through
um was that people were saying he didn't
ask about the movie at all and uh since
morbius has come out I believe it's
pretty apparent why there weren't any
movie related questions because you
don't ask questions about morbius ladies
and gentlemen no no morbius asks
questions about you so coming off the
post heroghasm clarity as I call it with
the penultimate episode of season three
it's been really incredible watching the
evolution of the boys and that's gonna
be the broad idea I'm gonna present to
you throughout the course of this video
see what initially started as this gory
and e-reverent deconstruction of
superheroes evolved into a gory and
irreverent deconstruction of human
nature throw in some satirical social
commentary for good measure and you have
a show that is arguably no longer even
about Twisted superheroes the closest
similarity I can think of for the
evolution of the boys is the Spartacus
series by stars if anyone remembers that
rest in peace to Andy Whitfield when
Spartacus first launched people were
very quick to dismiss it because they
perceived it as a bad 300 knockoff but
similar to the boys it became a show
about the human condition and the
nihilistic existential dread that
routinely pervades it and not to get all
political on you you as I'm about to
somewhat get political on you but we
live in a time when division
increasingly runs rampant on virtually
every issue I think over the last few
years especially since the Advent of
social media we've learned that humans
cannot agree on anything which makes you
wonder have we always been this way and
did social media just reveal it to us on
a global scale or that social media make
us this way where we can't seem to find
any Common Ground so you have to applaud
the boys for undertaking the vast
challenge of helping us see the
commonality of our existence the one
magical and Sublime quality that unites
us we're all crappy people I'm crappy
you're crappy he's crappy she's crappy
they're crappy we are all crappy people
who amount to nothing but a mere speckle
in the infinite fabric of the universe
and if you're saying to your yourself
now wait just a minute Karan speak for
yourself I am not a crappy person I feel
like the show was consistently showing
you that whatever moral righteousness we
believe we have when push comes to shove
our sense of morality is often the first
thing we're willing to sacrifice look at
someone like Starlight in episode 7. if
there's anyone who has even a modicum of
chance to represent the show's moral
compass it's her but what is she doing
in this episode cunningly recording and
exposing homelander to her 190 million
social media followers and don't get it
twisted I am not about to be a
homelander apologist I'm a pretty
ambitious person but I'm not gonna be
that ambitious uh just yet on the
internet at least I'm just presenting to
you the ask that this show has of its
audience and pondering the question that
even if homelander is the scum of the
universe does that mean he should have a
lesser expectation of privacy and who
should get to decide that should it be
judges should it be law enforcement
should it be elected officials should it
be the mighty or should it be the meek I
saw some discourse on social media and I
used that term discourse very Loosely
applauding Starlight for using her wits
to outsmart homelander by secretly
recording their conversation and of
course art is subjective but I fear
those who may be viewing the boys
through the lens of good versus evil May
potentially be missing the point of the
show entirely again that's why it's
fundamentally integral to the future of
humanity for all of us to acknowledge
that we're all crappy people I know that
sounds harsh but it's also a meta
commentary of the show itself the common
convention would have you believe that
this show is about Society elevating and
lionizing superheroes who in turn are
some of the worst people on the planet
but contrary to that belief the boys is
actually about conveying the idea that
anyone who thinks they have the world's
best interest in mind is capable of
wreaking inexplicable Havoc
acknowledging our crappiness just puts
us all on Common Ground at the onset for
example it was really easy to perceive a
character like butcher as a Neo Robin
Hood of sorts instead of balancing the
scales by robbing the rich and given to
the poor butcher would balance the
scales by protecting the public from
relying on soups who didn't have their
best interest in mind but again the boys
has consistently subverted certain
tropes and has placed itself in the rare
company of shows that are not only
impactful but can also facilitate these
types of conversations that we're having
at this very moment I'd like to draw
your attention to this quote from
butcher to Huey in the very first
episode a multi-billion dollar Global
industry supported by corporate
lobbyists and politicians on both sides
but the main reason that you won't hear
about it is because the public don't
want to know about it see people love
that cozy feeling that soups give them
some golden c word to swoop out of the
sky guy and save the day so you don't
have to do it yourself but if you knew
half the they were up to oh F and
diabolical but that's where I come in
I'm in to do what spank the bastards
when they get out of line just contrast
that quote from butcher's Evolution
going into the finale of season three
it's clear to me that the writers
skillfully played the card of
misdirection butcher is no better than
any of the swoops he despises I sound
like a broken record at this point but
our crappiness once again puts us all on
Common Ground which naturally begs the
question if we're all crappy people how
can anyone be a good person I obviously
haven't been in the writer's room but I
will take an educated guess that the
writers discussed empathy at one point
or another as a central tenant for this
show I can Envision someone in the
writing room go in if we can just make
the audience empathize with even some of
the most diabolical people then there
may be Hope For Humanity just yet think
about black noir also in episode 7. he's
a character that I honestly did not see
myself empathizing with in any form or
fashion even at the end of season 2 when
Queen mauve leaves him to succumb to his
tree nut allergy by stuffing an Almond
Joy in his mouth that felt like a moment
where the writers were tapping into some
of the vastness of the boys irreverent
humor this Stone Cold killer who
inspires trepidation wherever he goes
only for his greatest weakness to be a
tree nut allergy in the form of an
Almond Joy God I love the poetic irony
there but you get a sense that the
writers were being more mischievous when
that scene than wanting you to genuinely
empathize with the character but episode
7 represents a stark departure from the
irreverent mischievous humor to full-on
empathy black noir is a man carrying the
baggage from his past black noir is a
man unable to take full accountability
for his past black noir is a man who is
unable to heal from the past black noir
is a man who has no friends and the
company he keeps are mere projections
that are reminiscent of the Looney Tunes
by his conscious and or subconscious
wait just one second Amazon may need to
cut me a check because uh he's just like
me for real as we head into the finale I
want to leave you all with a bit of a
hot take assuming it sticks to Landing
the boys is inserting itself into the
conversation of all-time great shows it
has dynamic characters crazy moments
social commentary and a true modern day
villain with homelander which is why
Amazon should seriously consider season
4 being the final go out on a high note
as I've highlighted on this video The
boys has consistently proven to
challenge your beliefs on what kind of
show you even think it is but you have
to wonder as a fan how long can they
continue to do that at a high level I'm
looking forward to hearing from all of
you in the comments below how do you
feel about the points I raised what does
the boys mean to you what does it mean
to you in the long lineage of all time
great shows I know this wasn't a
tradition episodic breakdown but I hope
it does amplify your excitement about
the impact the show is having at least
on me going into the finale thank you
for your time and I will see you all
very soon